el uso de un dron por parte de Israel
para matar a tres milicianos palestinos
enim no solo supone el primer asesinato
selectivo aéreo en sí Jordania ocupada
desde 2006 sino un paso más en la
escalada de violencia sobre todo en el
norte según el ejército israelí los
hombres habían disparado desde un
automóvil contra el puesto de control
del chalame y minutos después se fueron
bombardeados por el dron un Elvis Hermes
450 usado regularmente en los bombardeos
en gaza este asesinato selectivo aéreo
se suma al uso de un helicóptero en la
redada del lunes también en cherín
medidas que no se utilizaban desde la
segunda intifada esto en medio de las
crecientes exigencias de los sectores
más extremistas de la coalición de
Benjamín netañahu que reclaman una
operación militar terrestre tras la
muerte de estos tres militantes en la
hija dinámica Palestina reconoció a dos
de ellos como sus miembros y prometió
venganza Mientras que el grupo islamista
jamás dijo que el uso de drones es una
escalada peligrosa por otro lado
mientras enchanin se vive una huelga
general
las dos aldeas palestinas hacen el
recuento de las últimas agresiones de
colonos israelíes que desde el martes
han atacado al menos 12 poblaciones como
venganza por la muerte de cuatro
israelíes en un ataque palestino en el
área de ramala una de las secreciones
más fuertes ocurrió en turbusaya donde
cientos de colonos destruyeron decenas
de vehículos y casas a plena luz del día
y sin que se produjeran arrestos en una
aldea en la que hay muchos habitantes
con nacionalidad estadounidense lo que
llevó a la oficina estadounidense de
asuntos palestinos a reclamar que se
garantice su seguridad en ese marco un
palestino de 27 años murió por un
disparo en el pecho que no está claro si
provino de soldados israelíes o de los
colonos